one of the things that I notice you do
really well in Song of Ice and Fire is
the foreshadowing there are thing you
know there are things in book three that
are foreshadowed as far back as book two
and maybe even book 1 and I was
wondering if you have difficulty
bouncing the foreshadowing with
spontaneity as a writer but manie's
things you for shadows and how do you
balance that with spontaneity do you
feel like you're straight jacketing
yourself to a certain plot no I don't
find that foreshadowing things lessons
to spontaneity my that I can see why you
think I might but if I don't know for
some reason it doesn't I don't I don't
have a formal outline I'm not one of
these writers who outlines every what's
gonna be in every scene what's gonna be
in every chapter I might be faster if I
did I did have to do that in Hollywood I
had never done that before when I got
the Hollywood I didn't want to do that
but they made me I kept saying just let
me write the script and then you'll see
how it comes out no no I have to have
the outline first so I got used to
outlining there but I never liked it it
did take away some of the spontaneity I
felt you know in some sense I had
already told the story even though I had
only told it in shorthand and retelling
retelling the story over again is not as
much fun as telling the story for the
first time it was a wonderful novel that
came out Oh a decade or more ago called
replay by Ken Grimwood some of you may
have read it science fiction novel it's
about a guy who wakes up one day he's
like a 45 year old businessman he has a
heart attack he dies he suddenly wakes
up he's he's 17 years old he's in his
college dormitory and he has this whole
life to live over it's you know it's
1970 68 again or whatever it is and it's
the story of what happens to him as he
lives that over and when I read that
book I thought about myself and what
would it what would it be like for me if
I suddenly was back at Northwestern it
was 1968 and I woke up and I'm a
freshman in my dormitory but I have all
my memories so I know what my life was
like and I know all the stories that I
wrote and it was actually a terrifying
thought because I said well wait a
minute
I have two writes and kings again you
know I it turned out pretty well the
last time but
I don't remember exactly how it goes I
mean what if I mess it up this time and
not only that but that I have to write
the bad stories again the ones that
nobody liked when they came out well can
I just like skip over them you know okay
so outlining is almost a little bit like
that it's it's it's like okay you told
the story once an outline now you have
to tell it again with like words and so
I prefer not to do that um Stephen King
wrote this great book called on writing
about the craft of writing and the first
scene he describes him and Amy Tan
sitting around a table talking about how
no one ever asked them these popular
fiction authors about the craft of
writing and I was wondering if you ever
sweat that stuff I mean do you consider
your sentences as much as say you know
John Irving or Tom Wolfe it sit there
and worry about stuff or do you find
that it's the story that compels you and
that drives you more than the language I
yeah I certainly consider my sentences I
don't know if I consider them as much as
Tom Wolfe or John Irving but I tell you
following those two guys is intimidating
and Neil Gaiman but those are two too
great writers of our time three too
great writers of our time with Neil in
there
particularly with the advent of
computers I think computers are you know
a great adjunct to rewriting I rewrite a
lot more in these days I'm constantly
polishing my prose and trying to trying
to get the sentence there of course I
have a lot of sentences in my books so
admittedly some of them get more more
attention than others but yeah the craft
of writing I mean is something that I
consider and it's something that I worry
about it's one of the hardest things I
mean I have the scenes in my head you
know I can see I can see how the battle
is going and now I have to get it into
your heads and I have to find the words
to do that and choosing those words the
right words that'll get the image across
and and you know make everything flow
and be exciting and have a certain
poetry itself it's it's very difficult
yes I was just wondering if how you keep
all this stuff from you know
plot lines and sub plot lines in your
and you keep them in your head do you
have a notebook or several notebooks
obviously with this guy I keep them in
my head that's why I need such a big hat
yes I I don't have I have a few pages of
notebooks and I have a few notes that I
keep things but no formal outlines and
you'd be surprised at how relatively
little there is so most of it is just in
my head god help me so I better not get
hit by a bus